you
[Music]
hi I'm Tom ball and it's my pleasure
today to welcome Eric harvested from CMU
he's doing his PhD and he's interviewing
today and tomorrow with Microsoft
Research for a postdoc position we
really look forward to hearing about his
who's worked on educational game design
welcome here thank you great so like I
mentioned I'm Eric harp said I feel I
have to introduce myself so the time
that you could talk anyway so today I'm
going to talk about some work that I
call Steam experience in many angles
educational dated educational game
design as the data-informed craft which
involves a lot of different kinds of
trust of research and all sort of get
into those as they go so so it's me
education I mean a certified by Oregon
Trail I grew up playing Oregon Trail
actually grew up blocks away from the
people that made Oregon Trail on the
minnesota educational computing
consortium but in the years since that
time educational games have should have
blossomed and grown to all these
different kinds of domains and fields
and interaction paradigms to really make
complex topics tangible and accessible
to learners of all different kinds but
what remains a challenge in educational
game design while has become more common
and more widespread it remains difficult
to really understand how we can best
support the design of compelling and
compelling games and transformative
instructional experiences so a lot of
people do it but how do we do it well
and ideally reliably well and why is
that a challenge and so to sort of get
into why that might be a challenge I
turn I mean I'm consumed you I can't get
away without citing herb Simon for
something um that herb Simon is this
famous quote in his discussions on Linux
science that learning results from what
a student doesn't thinks and only what
the student doesn't thinks the teacher
can advance learning only by influencing
what the student does to learn so
essentially as designers of
instructional technologies or
instructional experiences we don't cause
learning we build we build the area we
build the environment in which learning
happens we build the tools with which
learning is constructed
and and so you have to sort of view it
from that lens and there's a similar
analog in game design theory from the
what's called the MDA framework at the
mechanics dynamics aesthetics framework
that games are designed as this body of
mechanics or systems interactions and
and you can think about those as like
from a boardgame perspective it's what's
in the box that ship to the player from
a videogame perspective it's like it's
the card code that's actually running
the game and when a player comes into
that situation they have this dynamic
experience and they get to play with
sort of the emergent implications of
those mechanics to create a different
kind of experience and that arises to
aesthetics which are things like that's
where you would you would envision
things like fun or enjoyment but also
things like scholarship or abnegation
and that's where I would argue learning
also happens it happens sort of as the
thing arising out of this dynamic
experience coming out of mechanics that
we look at directly and another
implication of this MDA
perspective is that players and
designers have sort of cross purposes in
how they view the products they're
either making or playing with where
designers look and think largely about
these systems and the the tangible bits
and players care much more about sort of
the experience they take away and how it
arises out of those systems and
sometimes don't even get down to
thinking too deeply about the hardcore
mechanics themselves and so I say
central challenge of educational game
design is anticipating how your design
choices from your design perspective are
going to affect that player experience
and how that might give rise to learning
and so more concretely the work I'm
going to talk about deals with three
main thrusts so the first is providing
designers methods for seeing the
experiences their games or simulations
or environments create a second one of
exploring methods for evaluating those
experiences in terms of designers goals
and whether or not they seem to be
accomplishing what they're looking to do
and third developing tools to enable
designers to play with the implications
of experience within their own
environments
and so I'm going to talk briefly about a
project on each one of these thrusts and
how I think they entail sort of this
idea of an educational game design is a
data informed craft so first singing
experience so this thrust really tries
to answer the question of what does
experience look like what did what is
that dynamic emergent experience
actually look
like two players so one easy way of
getting at that is simply do a play test
you get a game give it to some kids or
to some players watch them listen to
their reactions their interpretations
maybe look at how they approach problems
but that well that gives you really
great rich data it's also sort of
focused on usually small scales so
another approach to taking more of an
analytic strategy these may or may not
look familiar to some people around here
the one on the left is actually a heat
map from Halo two developed by some of
the people over at user research and
then on the right is a the plate racer
system developed at the University of
Washington looking at sort of strategy
approaches through game space to a
solution and so there's lots of and
these are just sort of small samples of
them much much larger space of game
analytics strategies and in
understanding players at scale with data
and when I'm interested in is seeing
what I call solution space which is
essentially the space of all possible or
evolved functionally distinct ways of
solving an in-game leveller challenge
and that's important to know because how
people approach a problem or how they
solve a problem has implications on
either the knowledge they have the
knowledge they're acquiring and from an
instructional standpoint knowing that is
important to understand if you're if
your instructions working the way you
want it to be or if it could be
potentially designed differently and so
to introduce a more concrete example
just because it's necessary to
understand some of what's coming next
I'm going to juice the game rumble box
cellblocks is an education of this game
developed in collaboration with kind of
you knows entertainment Technology
Center it's like our game school if
we're not familiar with them and it's
designed to teach basic concepts of
balance and stability to kids in grades
K through 3 so giving them ways to play
with the notions of physics and so the
way the game works is players are trying
to build a block tower using a pallet of
blocks that can cover a series of energy
dots to power the alien spaceship so he
can fly away and so they're trying to
save the alien off to the side so that's
sort of the narrative purpose but what
this gives players the ability to do is
look at sort of what are the
implications of my structural design
choices as I'm building a tower and
playing with the notions of stability so
when they're done they put the ship on
top and this causes an earthquake and
sort of a test of stability of
structures and if the ship stays on top
they succeed and they move on and that's
sort of winning the game and if the ship
falls off the tower then the alien gets
sad and players have to retry and start
over and so what this definitely gives
players a sandbox to sort of work with
these different notions of of what
stability means using a metaphor that
makes sense to them so from a design
perspective on every game in rubble
blocks so this is just one example every
level normal box and I'll just highlight
the energy dots and the goal because
it's kind of hard to see on this
background um every game every level has
an intended solution so when the
designers are coming up with that
there's some way to solve the level they
know it's possible in some way but
there's a whole host of other possible
solutions the designers might not have
thought of because they're not capable
three kids or because they might have
missed some bug or something and it's
important for them to know what is this
space what does it look like how common
are some of these solutions do we like
some do we not like some for example the
the one in the the third one in the top
row actually looks kind of reasonable it
looks kind of interesting some of the
ones in the lower right look kind of
ridiculous and maybe shouldn't be
possible and it's helpful to know what
are these solutions and particularly
what are the solutions that players look
for and not say an exhaustive search of
all possible things people could do in
this space and so this is generally a
clustering problem and so what we're
looking to do is create clusters of
player solutions based on common
properties or approaches of what they do
and so conventional clustering is rarely
available thing anybody can import Sai
kit or Weka or whatever um but the
problem is game states are highly
structured and not easily amenable to
this kind of clustering approach and so
what we needed was a way to describe
game States and make them amenable to
clustering this is where we developed
what we call conceptual feature
extraction I sense have come to really
hate that name but the goal is
essentially what kinds of concepts are
exist in the solutions players create
and the way we did this was through a 10
dimensional grammar reduction process
where you take a game States you
discretize it to a grid
based on sort of the size of the single
square block and from there you learn a
2-dimensional exhaustive two-dimensional
context-free grammar across all the
solutions you have and so this is on
blocks that can be horizontally Jason or
vertically adjacent and then pairs and
pairs of blocks and etc until you have a
single block symbol and then there's
also extra rules in that I'm not going
to get into for handling negative space
for Chris ibly but from there you parse
the tower turn it into a feature vector
and then you can start to do
conventional clustering and so to test
whether or not this was a good idea
we had some human assistance take three
levels in the game that are sort of
minimally constrained so they're likely
to have lots of different kinds of ways
to be solved and we had human raters or
human assistance cluster a bunch of
screenshots of solutions to those levels
and then we had good conceptual feature
extraction using a G means algorithm
which is like k-means but trying to make
Gaussian clusters and then we compared
the result groupings against the human
is systems using adjusted R and index
which is like Cohen's Kappa but
generalize to the darker green or number
of groups grammar with spatial but what
do you see with a mutation of stability
right where you like it pointing
straight up that's much less stable in
our graduate but so so why not
incorporate that considering that's one
of your key K in terms of understanding
different what having perfect
um so that's one of the that's one
that's a part of the reason why I don't
like the conceptual feature name anymore
what we were looking for was sort of
looking at them distinctly and how
things can be solved whether or not
they're good or bad so we've looked at
and I'll get to some of this a little
later I'm sort of tangentially of
comparing these patterns to the stood
two measures of stability to see what is
good what is bad remember looking at
trying to map the space not necessarily
judge based at this point okay so
looking at the comparisons between
people and the machine we get airai's of
about 0.4 to 2.5 1 which is reasonable
for a sort of unsupervised strategy like
this but could probably be better
but you can do some interesting things
with this data as it is so here's a
graph of along the x-axis is all the
different levels in the game and on the
y-axis is the percentage of solutions
submitted to that level that adhered to
the envisioned solution so from like I
showed earlier and you can start to see
the things like the tutorial generally
people are doing what we expected to be
doing and as you go down it gets much
smaller this isn't actually the order in
which the game plays that would be
pretty amazing if this pattern just sort
of happened spontaneously but you can
also look at what is the distribution in
other solutions and so you see things
like down here where there's a very
common solution that's not the one you
envision and you can do analysis kind of
like this so G of U is great for doing
this kind of analysis but there's
several limitations to it so the first
the process of course to catch feature
engineering deciding on grammar rules
specifying what kinds of features the
sort of the complexity of the negative
space thing that I kind of allied it
over and so from a designer's standpoint
it's probably a little too intensive
pillsbury brittle so if you get new data
ins if you're doing like a sort of a
constant online analysis of what people
are doing in your game it has to relearn
an entirely new grammar when you get new
solutions in because it's not guaranteed
to be able to describe new data um you
write the rules that the types of rules
that can learn and then it learns a
grammar yes
yes and then there's also some
structures that just can't be described
using a 2d CFG like this spiral can't be
separated on potential axis so we have a
couple of solutions like this in our
data set and our solution for it right
now is to just simply treat them like
they don't exist which is not ideal and
so all of that was part of our
motivation behind developing the Tressel
algorithm which is a concept formation
algorithm and this time I actually
believe it's something more conceptual
than CFE that models the way humans
learn new concepts from structured
examples and so this is designed to
address two limitations of CFE in that
incremental it'll take in new data as it
comes in off the wire and it's designed
to take arbitrarily
structured JSON data so rather than
having to decide what are we how are we
going to describe our States or how are
we going to describe the rules that it
learns you can essentially just say JSON
export game state and it will work with
that you don't have to make views to
make a lot less decisions and then it
builds a conceptual hierarchy by
starting Institute's locally and
updating hierarchy during sorting select
Russell Birk says that follows three
major phases partial mastering
flattening cat organization and so
briefly the infant's representation
we're talking about here like I said is
the arbitrary structured JSON it can
have numerical values and nominal values
it can have component attributes which
are essentially sub diction like sub
objects or sub sub objects set up all
the way down and they can also have
relational data so it's technically a
superset of JSON where these describe
the relationship between two components
so saying like block one is on block two
and things like that and it takes that
into account when doing the partial
matching process so the first step is
partial matching where it has to rename
objects to maximize the expected number
correct as it could have at its root
concept so given a state coming in for
example this one if the UFO in previous
instances that previously been called
component 3 more often than it was
component 1 then you'll rename it
because they just aligned to the
structure better after that we flat me
instance out so you essentially take all
of the component structure and
describing an equivalent relational
terms and then you proceed through
categorization which is based on the
cobweb algorithm from Fisher back in the
80s and essentially what this is doing
is recursively moving an instance down
the tree entertaining things like
splitting nodes merging nodes creating
new nodes and at each point choosing
whichever option maximizes this notion
of category utility which is you can
think about is the expected number of
correct guesses for all attributes of an
instance rather than just one so it's
not like a decision tree which is
maximizing prediction of one thing it's
trying to balance maximizing its
predictions of all things and so we can
we did a similar analysis of the
clustering with Russell on to reduce
flat clusters by iteratively splitting
the
as you could do with any kind of
hierarchical clustering algorithm and so
each node that comes out of trestle is
essentially a probability table of
features and you can use things like a
cockade information criterion to
maximize a a log likelihood penalizing
for having too many clusters essentially
to choose the time to stop splitting and
we can take that flat clustering can
compare to the ones that come out of CSV
and we find in general it does as good
or slightly better than what the grammar
induction version did but there's also
arguably more information in this
hierarchy in its original hierarchical
organization then there is in the flat
one that comes out of comparing to CSV
so this is an example of a trestle tree
on that level that I showed earlier and
you can sort of see that among these
different groups if you can kind of see
those clusters that screenshots get a
little fuzzy um among the different
groups there's sort of a a relationship
among the patterns that you can see and
exploring this hierarchical
representation of the solution space is
potentially helping you understand
what's going on in it what so as a
designer I design image level I think
it's good for software but you might so
I might use it to say oh people might be
bees other exploration right here is
people might be doing yeah yeah and this
is sort of also add more the
unsupervised level of what is going on
in this space not judging it yeah I
didn't have to label it
ah not really this can take sort of an
arbitrary output of JSON it'll go a lot
slower if you do it 100 percent
arbitrary so you can cut out features
that never vary and things like that
um but you don't have to label much I
mean you do pass it in like level by
level because that's a label that's
important but um okay
running here uh not yet no well sort of
because these solutions are arrived at
by going through some dynamics but it's
not dynamic at this stage just as you're
getting all these wishes you're using
this debate costume okay here's a
cluster that we found hmm and then you
can line that up with what fashion label
and we give you the labeling technical
but the human labelling is pretty
arbitrary right I think you know whether
these two things are like each other or
not it's kind of a judgement call so I'm
curious elements I think one is how much
variance was there among the Cuba being
the labeling or the second question is
are there cases where you know you're
finding a culture with your automation
that is like humans would look at say
there's no way this is a culture right
um so because I forgot that I'm supposed
to be repeating questions uh so the
question was um what's the level of
agreeing between people and then is
there anything that we find in the
Machine that like the humans are like
this is stupid
basically uh I believe they agree
between the humans on the three levels
was like it's between point seven point
eight on average I don't remember I can
look it up afterwards
um it's relatively high for a RI um and
then there are times when you look at
the process and you sort of look I think
you can see some of these maybe where
particularly this group over here where
are these really that different or all
these really that like should they be
more merged or less merged and so
there's some questions of sort of is it
hitting a good level and some of that
happens because this is sort of an
incremental order dependent algorithm
and so there's elements of passing in
random sorts of stuff and having see
what happened what comes out the other
end or like burning in the data multiple
times to get a more reasonable structure
and that does happen to some extent and
that's sort of where you see some of the
variance in those a RI measures Melissa
the skiing experience to us
provides way for organizing the space
experiences players explore and and this
can help guide designers to sort of
portions of the space they might not
have been thinking about themselves or
seeing what comes out of it
the next arrest is sort of yeah will you
let's talk about any time when useless
with designer stand level thought so a
view uh I won't in the plan but I've
done some slightly different from that
particular vision saw but actually
taking it and taking those clusters that
come out and actually rendering them on
a grid of what feedback to the game give
on average and then different metrics of
stability and looking at does this
pattern align to what we would expect or
not and then having them use that to
come up with what would they change
about the game given the patterns
they're saying I've done some of that
sort of preliminary um and I'd like to
do a much better sort of more formal
evaluation of it I'm kind of more in the
piloting stage at that one but I can
point there's one graph I can point out
when I get to it that that is part of
that but so there's evaluating
experience thrust is sort of and now for
something completely different kind of
in that we're looking now here is is the
play experience working the way I want
it to be and in particularly what I'm
going to talk about here is the idea of
a learning curve so in games and in
software and in sort of general HDI
systems we have this idea of a learning
curve sort of colloquially of having a
steep learning curve is a really bad
thing it's really hard or having a
shallow learning curve makes things easy
but what does that really mean and how
can we talk about that at sort of a more
formal level and so the field of
intelligence tutoring systems is this
process called empirical learning curve
analysis which is technique for
comparing hypothesized models of skill
against actual player or student data
and so this is good for both evaluating
the difficulty and overall pace of
learning within an environment and then
mismatches in data and prediction can
really help to highlight incorrect
assumptions about what skills are in a
particular space and sort of a central
concept in this space is what Calvin
Ellis
opponent model so non-us components are
acquired unit of cognitive function that
can be inferred from performance on the
set of related tasks so essentially if
you have a knowledge component in your
head you will do good at tests that
require that knowledge component it's
relatively simple notion but what not
sponsor KC's are intended for is it to
be a unifying formalism for things like
skill fact ontology schema production
rule sort of a thing that can capture a
bunch of different ways of talking about
knowledge and learning and then a KC
model is a mapping between hypothesize
KC's and then game tasks or levels so so
you can have a model that looks like
this through down the y-axis I guess you
could have game tests it could be levels
they could be steps in a problem they
could be problems there's you can sort
of play with different and you ladies
there and then on the x-axis you have
different KC's that you hypothesized
each one of these tests exercises or
requires and so essentially this is a
big binary matrix conventionally called
key matrix in the literature and you can
take this with some real student data
and you can fit the additive factors
model which is possibly the most
unhelpfully named regression model ever
but it's a statistical model that uses
that is used to evaluate the fit of
difficut models to student performance
data and essentially the special form of
logistic regression it's like a
elaboration of item response theory if
you're familiar with that at all and
what it does is it encodes for general
assumptions about learning first all
students come into a test a different
initial levels of ability which is
modeled as a random intercept for
student all KC's have different initial
difficulties so all cases have a fixed
effects intercept for themselves all
KC's are roughly learned at the same
rate across students which is more unit
of simplifying formalism because you get
too many parameters otherwise mr. then
each KC has a slope of learning and then
crucially for what we're going to use
the model for KC's can't be unlearned
there's no forgetting in this model now
of course there's forgetting in the
world but what's important here is we
make the assumption that in working with
the task or a piece of instruction
students are learning something it might
not be the thing we thought they were
learning but we want to assume they are
learning and so what you're trying to do
is find
Kaycee model that makes it look like
they are learning and if you relax that
constraint and you have a bad KC model
you can sort of get free model fit by
allowing things to swing around more so
it's sort of a constraint in their
intended to hamstring overfitting and so
if you get out of fitting a model like
this is that is a learning curve that
looks something like this we're along
the x-axis we have opportunities to
practice a KC or skill so this is
essentially any step or level or
whatever that leverage that skill that
you did in the order you did them and
then on the y-axis we have a decreasing
error rate so conventionally these
curves are all modeled in terms of
decreasing error rates and so here a
steep learning curve is a good thing
because you're learning faster and a
shallow learning curve is a bad thing so
it's a little bit of a flip but the red
line that you can see is the actual data
from the students averaged it across the
opportunities without fitting any models
it's low as smooth for the graph but
it's not actually model fit in any way
and the blue line which I've mentioned
yet is is the fit from AFM it's the
actual prediction curve of AFM
so a good fitting model you should
expect the blue line to go ideally right
on top of the red line or through that
sort of pink hair Channel another
feature here that is worth pointing out
is that that confidence interval around
the real data is expanding as you go on
and the reason that happens is because
both in games and also in people are
leaving and so that's the so that's a
tail end so yeah
and instead conventionally the way these
are actually normally drawn is they
don't have the confidence level and you
just need to sort of be in the know that
n is dropping as you go and I find that
really confusing so this is a much
better way to look at it um but so to
demonstrate how I've used this technique
in the past have to introduce another
game sorry this is called Beanstalk it's
an education with this game again
developed in collaboration VT C and
again targeting K through three kids but
looking more this time at dynamics of
the balance beam and this is based on
some early cognitive psych research by
Robert Ziegler looking at
how kids reason in a balancing task in
particular in that if you remember a
balance beam they're sort of the weights
the weight on the on a placement and
then the distance in the fulcrum and
kids at this age particularly the k1 so
the earlier half of this spectrum
have trouble reasoning with those
multiple variables at once and how they
interact in a space so the way Bienstock
works is players are playing as either
jack or jackie and they're trying to
return the teddy bear to the monster in
the sky because it fell down and as
they're riding the beanstalk up to the
sky bugs keep falling on their beam and
forcing it out of balance and what they
have to do is grow flowers on places to
counteract the balance of the bugs and
so if they can balance it they get to
move on and the means that continues to
grill straight if they can't balance it
or they run out of water then jack falls
over and they have to restart now and
one thing you might not be able to see
is there's actually four positions here
too which are open and two of which are
currently blocked so we control how much
weight you can place and also where you
can place it is sort of the constraints
of the design space here so in doing KC
modeling and being stuck we iterated
through a series of models which is sort
of common practice in this in this
technique and the first thing we start
with which is a pretty common thing to
start with but also sort of meant to be
a strawman is then is the single KC
model so this is essentially saying
there is one nas component in this
entire game it is playing Beanstalk or
if you like balancing beams and it's
actually kind of a really bad assumption
it's like saying someone is good at
chess we like to say it colloquially but
there's actually sort of several
thousand if not million skills involved
in actually playing chess and and so
looking at it as a single unit skill is
actually not very appropriate and so
what we end up seeing for this KC model
fit to a single KC is the AFM fit models
essentially at effectively chance and
just a flat line there's basically no
learning and not much and it's sort of
flipping coin difficult and then the the
real data is also sort of kicking all
over the line which is a pretty good
indication of poor fit
understand that seems like people play
the game and this is just think maybe
they learned the game they play the game
hundred times the only is that because
the model is bad form doesn't really
nice okay what so what is the model
identical just said they they they learn
anything any what is it what is it so
the model is looking at as they get a
chance to practice this this sort of
global Beanstalk skill they should be
getting better and better as they go
like sort of completely monotonically no
relationship across like if there are
different kinds of design constraints or
different kinds of ways to think about a
level is that there's only one thing
that you have to do in this game and
generally doesn't work very well
it's like saying math is a skill when
really math is several subcomponent
skills and potentially appropriated
different age levels or grade levels but
at the macro scale it's generally not
very good so the first elaboration we
did to this model was taking it was
borrowing on that cognitive psych
research and looking at whether or not a
solution could be arrived at by purely
mirroring what was on the other side of
the beam or doing what the what secret
called a conflict balance case which is
essentially that the either the weights
of the distances on either side of the
beam weren't exactly the same but they
did bounce anyway and as you might
imagine the mirroring strategy is easier
so it's intercept is much lower and then
you're seeing learning and whereas
contrabands case is much more difficult
that's intercept is higher and there's
some learning but again the real data is
sort of kicking around and this is a
pretty good example of that that sort of
upward kick is a well-known pattern in
this kind of analysis and as you as you
remember I mentioned this sort of
assumes you cannot unlearn and so if you
find in the real data on learning is
happening it's not that they're
forgetting something or getting stupider
it's that they transition into a new
case see that you're not treating
differently right now that's generally
the assumption that we make in that case
so we liberated this more into a 6kc
model I'm not going to dig too much into
what all of these are but essentially we
left that that same mirror come back
down split but then added in the split
for how many pegs you have to deal with
on each side of the beam because that
just couple
it's the algebra of the problem so if
you have to add multiple positions and
then create multiple positions or single
single etc and so what I want to dig
into are these two which fit terribly
and so the this is the compact balance
for there's a single peg that you have
to put multiple tags on the answer side
and then a conflict balance where you
have to put multiple bags on both sides
so that's essentially the hardest thing
and to this point we've been doing what
we call rational cognitive task analysis
just kind of thinking about the problem
how do you have to how do you have to
think through it and how might we and
introduce new cases because of that but
for this next step we're going to do
empirical cognitive task analysis which
is looking at here you have oh sorry oh
yeah these are levels of the game and
then the red and green portions are the
actual error rates on those levels so if
it's mostly green as much easy it's a
very easy level if mostly red is
emotions very hard level and then that
blue line going through the middle is
the predictions of AFM for all of the
attempts on this level that make sense
and so if you see the blue line in the
green area that means this level is much
easier than we expected it to be if it's
in the red area it's much harder than I
expected to be and then there's actually
like 40 more levels in between these are
just the extremes um but so first we
looked at the solutions to some of these
levels in the easier side and here are
two examples can anybody potentially
guess why they're easier than expected
so they can all be solved by a shadow
strategy of just putting a single flower
in every open position you don't even
think about the math you don't think
about the physics you just click open
spots and you win and so we found that
well that's a problem and essentially
build a small detector to go through all
of our level designs and find places
where this is possible and retag those
levels with what we call the shallow
strategy KC oh the flowers
yes flowers yes yeah little spots on the
other yep well yep so we build a small
script to go through all of our level
specifications to find this problem and
tag it with the different KC and this is
what we see now
so that's ESM curve it's still a little
wavy but it's generally at least fitting
within the margin of error on the CMM
curve is just high and flat which is
disappointing but it's kind of what
you'd expected is the hardest skill in
the game and then the shallow strategy
just stays low and and never does so
much learning because it's essentially
you just get it for free and there's
actually some interesting properties in
the CSM one in that we give them like a
single stack of bugs and then they have
to put a single one on the other side
but not necessarily only on open spots
and what that does is it actually
factors out multiplication in the
algebra problem and so you get so
there's some interesting potential to
use this KC earlier in the game to sort
of transition kids more into those
conflict balance cases because it is
ultimately the only conflict balance KC
that actually shows learning there's a
business point so so essentially we
would say this is interesting we should
use it more often the CMM we might need
some more instruction either in the
classroom or in the game to sort of
bridge to those more complex cases and
we should probably cut anything that can
be flagged as shallow out of the game
essentially the the conclusion coming
out of this process yeah
either all sort of fun crosses learning
in the census is distinct don't are told
that there's concepts that they need to
understand early that are important that
would connect their effort to the
concept because if you have typical key
changes and sort of given a concept
mechanism an opportunity to practice so
um they are not told explicitly about
these labels or things related to this
label there is some instruction in the
game um and sort of guiding them towards
thinking about certain things but there
were several conditions in this study so
there's like one condition where there
wasn't a lot of that direct guidance and
other ones where they did like a like a
scientific inquiry process of here's a
being here's a situation predict what's
going to happen let's observe what
happened why do you think that didn't
happen and sort of working through that
so it did kind of vary a bit but another
thing is in doing this sort of process
of sort of playing with changing these
kaci labels is you're sort of walking
away from whatever instruction actually
was in the game to try and look at what
did they can we find evidence for what
they seem to actually be learning
irrespective of what the game was
communicating to them that make sense
yeah I think it's an interesting
question to think about every morning I
guess a monument and so there's also um
in the feedback the game gives its light
it's less clear in it's less messy in
the Beanstalk case much more in the
rumble box case I have other research on
that that I not going to talk too much
about of the feedback the game gives is
sort of implicitly communicating some
kind of truths or like some kind of
principles and your goal is the
designers to make sure that the
principles is communicating are the ones
you actually want it to be communicating
that make sense the shallows they want
to get rid of those is that because
they're just too easy
people don't even to actually interfere
with um so it's actually you bring up
Anna so question again sorry what in the
shell when I said I want to get rid of
them is that because they don't
contribute to learning or they're too
easy is that basically or they interfere
sure there's actually interesting point
there and it's a little more nuanced
that my adviser Vincent no even has some
interesting ideas of I say get rid of
them because they're too easy
they don't necessarily interfere with
learning um but he said actually you
could use them as sort of red herrings
so introduce them early on and then
immediately followed up as a level it
doesn't work and sort of use it as like
acknowledge this is a shallow strategy
and that it's wrong and that actually is
an interesting concept that you could
also do for real the other thing is also
the lonely kid is playing a game having
success right increasing motivation
right please do be beneficial for there
yeah yeah and there's also yeah we had
been looking have been looking too much
as sort of those engagement level things
here of if the game too hard too easy
things like that I actually forget what
the base rate success is unrunnable unbe
not and if a rumba block that's
relatively high and kids are generally
engaged but uh yeah even how long really
to be efficient on anything graduate but
you make fun discovery at some level so
Beanstalk hasn't been iterated
at least not based on this data it's
actually transformed into three or four
other games since but not since this was
done um and the number of students it's
somewhere in the range of 150 ish we
should be all of these things on
describing are about 150 of kids in a
dataset Rumble blocks I have been doing
some iteration and that's sort of
getting into my next thing so I'll talk
a bit about that so to wrap up on
evaluating experience um looking at ways
to consider experience against designer
expectations and sort of question those
in the context of data so my next one is
playing with experience and this is sort
of the bulk of where my thesis research
lives so essentially the first two
thrusts are what's going on instead of
the dynamic so that emerging quality of
your game
the second thrust is now as you see that
do you like it as a good as bad playing
with experiences or what do you change
something now is it better and so this
stress largely centers around what I
called replay analysis which is using
in-game replays of players to support
very different kinds of analyses and so
these replays are interesting because
they make that ephemeral experience
something tangible and concrete that can
be examined and molded and sort of
played with and in this work I've
created what I call the replay analysis
system which is a system built in the
Unity game engine that helps facilitate
replay analysis and there's two major
components to it one is a logger for
logging when players are playing and
then following up on that is the replay
now engine which sort of takes that log
plays it back in the game and allows
this kind of analysis so logs I'm taking
our recording of action situated in game
context this is not an input stream like
a click so in Rumble blocks its pickup
block at position X Y release block at
position X Y and that is a feature
engineering thing a designer must do
rather than saying click down click up
but
why that's interesting well getting why
the why that's important will get a
little interesting in a bit but
essentially each one of these records
comes with four features a selection
action input which is a common paradigm
and intelligent tutoring systems for
describing actions which essentially the
target of an action effectively the verb
and then the inputs is a list of
parameters to that action and then the
state at the time of the action and this
is mainly because I don't want to trust
interpolation because physics engines
are messy and then the replay analysis
engine assistant built on top of the
normal gameplay engine the reasons logs
in and an act reenact secession and then
allows for various metric calculations
feature abstractions of things like that
and the way that generally works is
given a given a particular record in a
log trace first it as soon as the state
associated with that action essentially
provides then
the action better fighting the inputs to
whatever function ran that action waits
for some stopping condition calculates
and interpretation to the state and then
moves to the next record effectively how
normal replay works and what's really
useful about this is you're in the
context of the original game engine with
all of the original sort of live code
back again so rather than deciding on a
couple metrics running a study and
having data if you thought oh well what
if we'd recorded this other thing you
don't have it then whereas here you do
and so I've used this process on what I
call the sort of retrospective replay
now is on rebel blocks you lots of
different kinds of stuff I'm just going
to sort of briefly rolling through some
of this but essentially so the three
main goals in rumble blocks are kids
teaching kids that think of wider bases
are more stable things that are
symmetrical and more stable and things
with lower centers of mass and we're
stable and what's nice for us is those
are all calculable metrics or they have
sort of associate calculon metrics and
we can look at do they perform those
metrics better or worse early in the
game versus late in the game
you can look at how do we provide
feedback in relation to the actual
metrics in the engine do we like the way
that pattern works this was some of the
analysis with designers I was talking
about where on this x-axis we have one
of the metrics and on the y-axis we have
what is the general success ratio for
particular cluster of levels and we've
also looked at of those CFE features
which ones are more indicative of
succeeding or failing and we found an
interesting pattern there that one of
the strongest things that matters is
what you put the spaceship on
essentially is it on a wide platform or
a skinny platform and sort of
irrespective of the rest of your
structure is it going to topple off the
top um and so that's potentially a
problem and so we've done lots of
different kinds of analysis and from
there we have some interesting ideas
about what we might want to do next so
for example with the spaceship problem
what if instead of having this fish
would fall off the tower for success it
just kind of floated there and it was
about capturing the energy dots possibly
one way to fix that problem another one
is that really these metrics are all
kind of about single connected rigid
bodies and rather than a bunch of
separate blocks and so what if we glued
them all together and how to work that
way instead so you have several
different ideas that come out of this
kind of analysis we want to know are
they going to be better and so this is
where we reintroduce what I call
projective plane
which is essentially taking the
historical replay data and sending it
through a changed iteration of the game
to understand if this new version is
better or worse and what this does as an
agent component to the system for
handling the ambiguities between that
old version and the new version
and I'm exploring three different
versions of this agent system what I
call a literal projected replay which is
just run which you had before and if you
hit an impasse of that action there's no
longer applicable or something you just
fail but it's cheap and easy so why not
try it and the flexible projective
replay which adds a more intelligent
agent behind the scenes based on the
trestle algorithm was talking about
before and a planner to understand how
to work in new space so when that
flexible agent works is existing player
recordings are used as training
demonstrations to an AI agent system
that then plays the game and so the the
way that the way that training system
works is first demonstrated actions so
the recordings from the previous players
are explained using an iterative
deepening planner and a set of
transformation functions to find a
general explanation for the actions
inputs so for example if I were to have
placing this Block in this position you
could explain that in reference to say
the x value of this dot and the Y value
of this square you could use a function
like plus a block or like a block away
from this rectangle for its height and
then also a block away from the center
of the rectangle or you could use say in
the middle of two things to describe
where did the particular parameters of
that action come from and then from
there the state is paired with game
feedback and associated into a trestle
knowledge base so another classifier
when that action is applicable and so
like so previously I mentioned Trussell
was a clustering algorithm and so here
I'm using it for classification and that
seems a little weird so why am i doing
that so part of the motivation behind or
the evaluation we did when we developed
Russell was does it actually make
decisions in a similar way
a to people and so what we did here was
this we took a bunch of mechanical
triggers and gave them a task looking at
a picture of a tower of normal blocks
and saying is this category 1 or
category 2 where in this case category 1
is standard category 2 digit fall we
wanted to do it at this sort of abstract
level so that the turkeys would have a
sort of a similar level of domain
knowledge to the space as the agent
would and then once they made a decision
we told them if it was one of the other
and then went on to another grapple and
then we kept doing this for I think it
was so at 30 or 20 30 30 items and so
this is the result of that where the
blue line are the humans it's the only
20 humans I think so we probably could
do to have a few more but then this
green line is a decision tree using the
exception feature extraction grammar
rules and then the red line is trestle
performing this task using just a
standard JSON representation and the
feedback and so originally what we had
when we first ran this was the decision
tree and trestle and we were all kind of
sad because accesible sort of gets
better and then it gets worse and like
well that's not great we would like a
machine learning algorithm that just
gets better and tastes better but then
when we ran humans we actually found out
that humans have this similar kind of
reversal effect and we think one of the
main reasons for that is sort of the
trestle has a way of sort of indirectly
modeling the idea for getting by losing
a retrieval path information because
it's sort of constantly restructuring
its knowledge base and humans have a
similar kind of pattern where rather
than rather than thinking about
forgetting is you you've deleted
knowledge is that you've know under
found you don't want remember how to
find it essentially and you can have a
similar kind of pattern Explorer here so
so Tercel makes sense in this
classification sense for this agent to
understand success based on state yeah
anything everything
initially design yes and so instead we
decided instead of like an item 11 yeah
very cute it's got that one right is
that correct yes yeah so it had to do is
actually the difficulty of the problem
and important to that so the question
was about is this crunchy presented and
the difficulty of the problem the humans
are always seeing a random sort of
towers so some of this is just kind of
the noise came out of that the 11 things
um I'm not I'm not I'm not sure I can
say it was always different but it was
random there's a very low performance is
it accidental that it happened to be
that on the 11th thing it was hard for
me yeah yeah yeah and really chance here
is like should be here because it's
essentially randomly picking between two
labels yeah in low performance it
randomly yeah yeah yeah um but but they
do eventually start getting sort of what
is the pattern here and some of that it
is kind of it is kind of a really
difficult task to do with zero context
of is this one or two and like what is
one in two mean what are you trying like
what are you trying to have me right
here um but that is roughly equivalent
to what the agent is doing yeah so um
one category one no no literally they
just one or two and then we told them if
every if they were right or not when
they liked the game basically yeah yeah
oh because we wanted we wanted to stay
abstract because that would be
equivalent to what the agent would have
so is there any chance that after 11
items you're modeling fatigue of
annoying game mmm as opposed to
something that could keep their
attention for that long I hadn't thought
about that it is possible that there's
sort of some fatigue element going on
like if you model again your air bars on
thank the confidence to go hmm did
everybody laugh yeah yeah granted it's
only 20 people that's one of the issues
I actually do have a version with the
error bars and it's actually like way
more compelling than this but this is
true I can show you that if you want
it's actually a really great grab
because because when you when you model
with the error bars so essentially the
trusted line lines up right through the
center of the human data almost
perfectly um they seem to be performing
balance yes wait yes so actually 11 was
easier
this is error yeah so 11 happened to be
easier for people buy more of an
annoyance effect those both right yeah
cool it might also have something to do
with flow right inaudible keeping them
in the flow and after a certain point
yeah it's interesting that trestle would
have that you would expect that an agent
would be level 7 who would not be
detectable this right yeah yeah so the
way that the flexible agent works in
comparison to the retrospective replay
essentially give it a new game state
does the agent have an applicable action
if it does perform it it doesn't
essentially a simple recognized act
cycle then wait for the stopping
addition that the game has feedback if
no add it to some list for this attempt
and once we do a feedback we sort of
back propagate that feedback and train
the whole attempt at once because an
issue with this agent is it's only
getting feedback at the end of a level
and not action by action like it would
want Tom
so ammonium is an ongoing evaluation I
don't have a lot of great final data on
this yet I'm actually running my final
play test of rebel blocks next Monday
where what we've done is we've reduced
several variations of the original
roblox game so things like removing
spaceship as a mechanic
um gluing the blocks together one idea
was taking the cliff away because it
gets in the way of some things and
performing a bunch of different virtual
play test using both litter around
flexible agents in those spaces and then
performing a new classroom study using
two of those variations with real people
to see if the conclusions we reached
through virtual play tests result in on
similar conclusions that we would have
done if we just done a new play test
with people again and so well be looking
at comparing the level overlap between
the solution space is generated by each
system and then also looking at the
those alignment measures of do these
principles in the game correspond to
positive or negative feedback in a way
that we would like and so I'm playing
experience this gives us diners the
ability to treat experience like
material and allows for rapid virtual
play testing and Russian testing and
things like that new ideas and so taken
together I give you sort of three
thrusts as moving towards educational
game design at the data-informed craft
of how people see the implications of
what they make think about whether or
not those correspond to their goals and
their ideas and then develop ways for
players to actually for designer
sexually play with implications of new
choices and and designs before actually
going getting new huge play tests of
people sort of as a more rapid iteration
loop so that looking to some future work
which I've tried to tailor a little bit
around what I might do that was here so
one thing I'd love to do is start
applying some of this stuff to more
domains so a lot of the programming
tasks and things like you're working on
to make code work I'm really similar
properties for the game spaces that work
done so far they're essentially just big
creative tests with complex structure
and everything I've done here is pretty
applicable to those admittedly the
structure is different so like grammar
is much more formal in something like a
program than it is in two dimensional
blocks world but other kinds of
approaches work we've done some we're
trying to fit trussel models with some
Alice data it's messy but it does
actually learn some kind of structure
there's an earlier version of Trussell
too though so I don't remember what was
interesting about that or what came out
of it like
be used but then also another thing I'm
really interested in is how to define
knowledge components and do that kind of
learning curve analysis in a programming
domain we have some we've done some work
on that where we defined a knowledge
component at a token level so
essentially does this token exist in a
like a ta solution as a correct or
incorrect extremely messy fits terribly
but it was a good first shot and and
really the harder problem there is was
an opportunity to practice a skill when
you're programming and there's also
elements if you're probably exercising
multiple skills or you're probably
exercising multiple cases and in sort of
the edits you make to a program before
you submit it to get some kind of
feedback and so tearing that out is also
interesting yeah is the notion
something's unstable visible to the user
if they put like like if I had a block
like this night plays like this when I
just yell so there's an element of
learning as you go about stability with
that with that visible to the see the
RPA in the sense that you had as a
measure of these actions right but were
some of the actions failed actions where
it caused you know the black students
employers place um yeah so there are
several ways I handle that for the agent
in the replay er arm but it's a so it's
a little complicated um essentially a
failed action to the agent is if
essentially inaction results in no
change so if it like picks a block up
and then drops it and then it falls back
where it was before like that was a
failed action in that learns that is a
failed action but things like trying to
put like if I take the block and I try
to just put it in the ground or
something like that
thankfully it doesn't do that very much
but I mostly just kind of treat those as
that didn't work and move on
there are ways I could handle that much
more elegantly or more intelligently
that's another piece of future work but
I didn't include emissive of there's
several impasse points in that process
because it's kind of complicated and
right now most of the my answer to most
of those impasses is pump but there are
several ways it could be done better
and so the budget ear your point of the
sort of situational feedback of like the
towers falling over but just because
it's a real-time physics engine
that's not explicitly captured in in the
replay er but it doesn't note like it
does see that the world is different
when it's in a new situation so it'll
try to do that and me probably be you
know people that haven't been back there
yeah in their code before they've been
that right there you don't see every one
of those and see how they responded to
them and you're not going to really try
writer for the pine green learning
process right right yeah
so the another piece pedro recommends is
sort of lowering various entry to this
kind of analysis and this kind of work
so currently you need to sort of have a
lot of research expertise and
development expertise to use most of
what I've done
um and what I'd like to do is develop
methods for Bergin with games or
instructional environments so that
somebody like just a standard teacher or
just an instructional designer could
actually employ some of these things as
they're built in more to a tool than
then what I've done so far and so this
is sort of some of that work I was
talking about with the designers of how
do they think about this how would they
like to think about this is this
actually fitting a need that they have
or is this something completely stupid
um I'm looking more into that is
definitely a thing I'm also interested
in so that acknowledgments to my mentor
is my various collaborators most of this
was funded by DARPA and also the peer
program it's Union and with that I'll
take questions so I've kind of already
taken a bunch symmetry that thing that
the performance law understands about
symmetry
the cemetery angle on average was lower
which is a good thing sorry
because soda symmetry to the way yeah
sorry it helps if I actually dig into
these more so there's three metrics were
using wide base just the width of the
aggregate base of the tower
center mass is the height of where the
aggregate center of mass is off the
ground cemetery angle is a complicated
way of measuring symmetry of taking a
ray from the center of base through the
center of mass and it's absolutely
different from ninety like this so lower
is better lower is better is actually in
both of these two and higher the better
space so center mass not doing very well
trending wrong but also not significant
wrecks it you're teaching physical
content and you thought about comparing
with teaching the doctrine well yeah so
there's a bunch of work by Ezra linear
at CMU so she was also sort of part of
this work originally and she has gone
and done a lot of physical stuff and
also interestingly detecting them with
connects and things like that of trying
to do some of these predictions with
powers the kids just build out of Legos
and letting them go through a process
before the tables actually shaked and
she actually just recently defended her
thesis so there's a bunch of stuff on
that the parents this general would take
away a physical is way better but it's
also sort of physically constrained yeah
how many of the games that you thought
that today were you know for the purpose
of actually teaching kids versus for
your dissertation so the games were
built primarily for the purpose of
teaching kids that's what these so the
original the engaged projects you might
have seen the badge show up it resulted
was a collaboration between CMU's energy
Emma Technology Center and then also the
HCI
where students games of the EPC would
build these games for purposes of
essentially stem and physics for that K
to three range which is why they all the
same grade range and then we would do
the analysis and evaluation and also
guidance on sort of pedagogical design
and I would say that process is
potentially more swung to their side of
the design
and development in the rumble box case
so the rumble box is much more driven by
by their side of the equation Beanstalk
was a little more driven by our side of
the equation which is why it's more
based on cognitive processes cognitive
research but near the original intended
goal was a teaching and I've sort of
co-opted them because I'm sitting on the
pile of data from all of them and I can
use that how well do we the purchase
scale because one of the things with the
face is danger you're doing and the age
of the ledger focusing happens you can
rid of it as a really finite problem
what happens when you get things with
lots of variables or logic knowledge
concept as it complexity increases
what's your thought sure um so the
question is how one of these approaches
scale
particularly when sort of things like
you get more concepts and more knowledge
components and things like that so the
the knowledge component one the the
empirical learning curve analysis thing
that's actually been done by it so
that's kind of like a bread and butter
piece of the educational data mining
community and that can scale sort of
lots of different ways but usually
because it's working in well-structured
curricula where you have like lessons
you have problems and lessons and units
and you can sort of leverage the fact
that each individual modeling problem
isn't necessarily the full enormous set
um but if you did have a place like that
it's honestly probably more a challenge
of what do we think these knowledge
components are do we believe that they
make cognitive sense if you're dealing
with enormous data there's also a lot of
approaches for learning knowledge
component models sort of unsupervised we
and and those I think are the places
where you start running into some scale
issues of we learned this model but what
does the model mean and but in terms of
actually doing the fitting and looking
at the person it's mostly it's mostly a
grunt work problem at that point but it
does doesn't really scale um in terms of
trestle that's the thing that I think we
actually don't have as great
and intuition about is how well
something might Russell skills I mean
it'll take sort of arbitrarily giant
states and arbitrarily giant sets of
data but a thing that I would really
like to do potentially a little more
rigorously and evaluating the algorithm
is understanding how certain
relationships between features kind of
affects things and can you bias its
processes by how data is encoded when
you feed it in ideally it wouldn't be
but it probably is in some ways that are
maybe not as obvious on the tin